i don't get the confederate flag maybe  it's because i grew up in new york but  it just doesn't make sense to me like i  know a lot of people say that that flag  is about the history but that one  definitely about the racism  having a confederate flag is like having  photos of your ex-girlfriend up all over  your apartment  and then inviting your new girlfriend  over to your apartment  and being like oh these know it's  nothing weird it's just about our  history together  oh what do i want to do for fun i was  thinking maybe you could dress up as my  ex-girlfriend  we'd go back to our old apartment  reenact fights we used to have  for the history